so i go into the army
and i'm in south carolina okay and then
we go to uh uh fort campbell kentucky
i'm in fort campbell kentucky so guys i
sort of pizza so yeah perfect sort of
papa john's i said is that a local place
no everybody eats papa john's i've never
heard of papa john's so we're talking
about i'm in california i've never heard
of papa john's he says dude it's the
best pizza i said papa john's yeah i'm
not ordering papa john's what's their
little caesars dude just try papa john's
so they bring papa john's
this is september of 97. you remember
the day i tell you i can tell you this
because it's the like when you go boot
camp in ait for six months and you don't
eat pizza the first time you eat pizza
it's like a 16 year old boy for his
first time experiences you know the
magic of you know what you call some
crazy bread crumb crumbs some crazy
bread yeah
so anyway so i eat this papa john's
pizza but what what what got me hooked
wasn't the pizza john
when i dip that pizza into that garlic
sauce that you have game over for me